welcome to this video shushing hi wh
yeah that's one of the more frequent
opponents d three years at a mall slip
but it's not so terrible so what am I
going to do him with f5 on Condit's
let's play healthy chess develop stuff
yeah do I play with f5 here let's try
that well so much for healthy chess well
okay but I think I'm that's probably not
that bad the Grand Prix reversed okay
like age six and he's going for 95 here
maybe I don't know
yeah it looks a bit tricky don't like it
so much that he was able to trade them
but what can you do not to be three
maybe if I go a four you might just
retreat and take this pawn ok I'm going
to put the bishop out first then you can
put 93 though didn't
okay if you place Knight c3 night x
therefore that at least takes a long
while and in the meantime I'm going to
have that sort of very dangerous a check
to be perfectly honest there there's
some kind of tactical refutation or
something idea that i can go for not
really am ok let's go I for that sets
rather questionable all of that let's
see night a for it comes with the tempo
in some way against the bishop maybe
maybe it's okay like if I take them okay
I can take now on g3 I think I should do
that and now well he is threatening to
take on c5 let's preserve the bishop it
looks like a potentially dangerous piece
yeah so I'm going to go Quinn here 494
Bishop g4 isn't that isn't that
dangerous I'm upon down but it looks
kind of dangerous to me so Knight to g4
or Bishop g4 first
maybe night 94s maybe bit more forceful
Jeff III this Bishop g4 neither three
which is both good push-up gvoice
stronger I guess yeah okay he's on the
back foot bishop g-form Chum this
doesn't he doesn't even have not
something to have 3m it's very very
dangerous yeah how does he put a protect
you too yeah i know i don't see how 93
I'm just just taking
huh has a bit lucky I really neglected
the queenside quite a bit but the coming
attack here proved to be very strong
okay so let's see i'm taking let's do
that right that's what I'm trying to
trying the same what is the the best way
to play this Ruger three right go three
killed check don't want just the porn or
something this is white check resigns
yeah there was a bit lucky because I
really underestimated the queenside
issues and I got I got great got a great
attack quite out of out of nowhere
probably there was some way for him to
defend them this F for its kind of
dangerous after that the compass giving
me a big edge already hmm computer wants
to go King h1 in this position yeah
maybe there is a point to again then
then you can really recapture with the F
on
hmm yeah that looks okay right just
delaying the capture you can still take
this is what is the comp giving you
start to get a feel for what what it
what it calculates them that gives gives
us this equal which is really a funny
fun day evaluation and back I don't know
check ya black has an initiative there
on the well that's a cool computer line
Queen B 394 Queen B seven and still says
equal maybe yeah very very tricky yeah
so let's see what is this then III is
better here my dear for this is probably
too greedy again III seems to somewhat
hoard it turn surprises me why isn't
Bishop g4 strong here queen bee three
and the computer says white is better
really wow that is some kind of
surprising
jam maybe yeah maybe it looks very
dangerous yeah I have those Bishop e3
rook f3 kind of moves but those two
pieces are not really plane yeah maybe
sometimes the computer is under
estimating the tech because it's
sometimes give it kind of sometimes we
have those crawling attacks yeah where
you build up behind formation yeah let's
say rook f3 look f8 so the long term
stuff but my queen side is falling apart
so I think the computer is probably
right down that this is good that this
is good term it's good for wide it gives
however this which I probably wouldn't
have played with about equal play
getting the pawn back now I would have
gone for the attack but here it here it
will be here it is difficult still
computer says before it's not that bad
okay but this is bad yeah yeah here I'm
winning yeah it's so difficult yet to
defend against this kind of attack as
all the pieces are kind of in play
before we should be form I Bishop g2 I
mean which well that's the idea of
before yes chair covering from the side
which is still not yet clear as
dangerous as it looks this is clear now
it is over yeah I know k 3 rucca three
definitely kills there yeah satisfied it
was a fun game but um tricky business
but always there is some danger about
those kingside attacks for sure okay
well thanks for watching